it's the fighter and the kid had to run
it back cause we back at it again yeah
we gon keep it moving like it's never
gonna end when it was brendan when it
was brian when he was just talking to
friends we got the kid calling on the
left with the fighter on the right had
to do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
we're out come on baby
we have a lot to talk about how you
feeling buddy fresh off the plane phone
oh well what i love i love new york in
the summer where when you take three
steps you're already covered in soot and
sweat that's a great time and some of
the like
like
yeah fog or smog yeah well it's a
mixture of and then the urine that's
always on the street kind of mixing with
all
my family has a little apartment there
so i say little i've been in there the
thing is
i told you when you told me you're
staying there
that's right i forgot about that well
it's a one bedroom it's not a massive
but it's a nice apartment it's not the
one next door too but yeah we got a
little uh got a little uh pierre terra
there but that's not something we own
apparently my mom rents that rents it
out yeah no she rents that so we only
have but i told her to buy that so you
know but everything's kind of expensive
it's nice out there that's a good area
it's a good area so i spend my time
downtown so you you get you you're gonna
sweat then what you do is you go down
make sure you go down to the subway
where it's about 20 degrees hotter so
new york now there's because of the san
gennaro festival one million additional
people are downtown
one million additional
people who don't live there they're in
the pandavas from elsewhere oh oh yeah
because no one works yeah so it's one
million people that's correct sir now
try driving which i did i drove out to
joey diaz's house oh i was just awesome
the best we had a great podcast he's the
best we had it was so i love him yes
and he's out there in jersey and just
doing it he's in the burbs out there an
hour outside jersey good friend outside
of new york and we talked about that and
uh he's life is good for joey he's he's
feeling good out there he thinks it's
the right decision
he's not moving austin no did you bring
it up he's a jersey guy bro yeah oh i
wouldn't bring hey i wouldn't bring
austin up yeah around joey diaz not when
he's in jersey he's got his restaurants
he's like these staten island italians
they don't [ __ ] around bro yeah they
don't [ __ ] around i would have taken you
out and knocked your dick in the dirt
yeah because he's got all his wrestling
i'm sorry was that sammy the bull or is
that a joke you know what that was a
combination
my my joey diaz impersonation is come on
yeah you gotta go deeper but we had a
great time we had a great talk so you
did you did joey diaz uh i did legion of
skanks you're your buddies at
the had the skanks they're my good
friends
and uh i can't even tell you who's all
on there i know i know
uh but um but big j okay
yep yep great comic too but but we had a
great time but it's it's also like it's
it's like being in a coliseum dan soder
still on there no
i thought soder was part of that because
soda is a denver guy he's hilarious
yeah it was yeah it's dan it's big j dan
soder yeah
is that the ford like the
and dan dan smith
dave smith it's not dan i'm so sorry
sorry i don't think i've ever remembered
dave you call him dan
you met him he said you were really nice
to him i don't know but anyway but dave
dave dave's great and we had a great
time and those fans are [ __ ] rowdy as
[ __ ] and it was uh the whole thing was
crazy they hooked me up to a lie
detector and asked me all these
questions and like a legit light
detector yeah it's a police lie detector
and i'm like sitting there is there a
girl there's a real guy doing the actual
thing well they asked
is that a comic thing no it's the guy
who runs a legit guy so he he asks you
some baseline questions are you a male
one of the questions he asked me when i
was doing is he goes have you ever
wished anybody dead i was like yes oh
wow yeah
yeah which i'm sorry to say well at
least you're telling the truth what else
did they ask you how many questions was
it totally they asked me five questions
only five yes yes uh they said uh and
the big one was do you think brennan
schaab is funny and i said yes without
hesitation
and uh and i was telling the truth so
there you go buddy and then what were
the other questions um
uh
one was funny well he goes do you
respect louis j gomez i don't know louis
very well so i was like yes victim for
in regards
that was just one of the clubs they
roast each other to death they the one
thing about new york
is that
new york comedy and those [ __ ]
are new york like big jay's from philly
but you may as well be from new york to
say you know building here
the way you you interact i think louis
is puerto rican from [ __ ] like the
bronx you cannot go to school high
school there or middle school without
essentially having the toughest shell in
the world because the way people
interact is basically to try to destroy
jobs oh dude it's just
roasting i believe i don't have the data
that's how most guys are yes whether
it's new york or like yeah grow up in a
locker room like ghosts correct correct
they're just getting lit up so those are
some different those guys take it to a
to a level yeah they get dark yeah bro
they get dark and i'm i'm i got a pretty
tough shell but i ain't dark i was like
this a lot i was like oh jesus you know
like big j because they didn't already
[ __ ] in the cup before was that on
legion i don't know but anyway so so so
we we uh so
we we do this this whole thing and it
was a [ __ ] it was big j
is funny as [ __ ]
big jay officer
rated big holy [ __ ] you should have done
the serious show with big jane dan soder
it's the funnest funnest time i've had
to impress oh really they have a show on
sirius yeah dude and they're talking
about uh dance center's great uh i think
they're talking about catch a predator
or there's something like some
uh crime show they're [ __ ] hilar yeah
soda soda's from denver now they're both
smoky hill we're rivals okay okay so so
he played yeah i think he played
football just in high school but he's
he's best coming out of denver he's
funny as [ __ ] dancing
man soda and big j that's a that's a
hell of a team do they have a show on
sirius yeah here's my question i think
they still do here's my question why are
you on serious
do your own thing yeah well yeah maybe
but i think i don't know but also like
when my when our boy jason ellis was on
there he's getting a million dollars a
year a flat fee all right hey i'm also
i'm sure good amount of money i'm all
about it then
well no but big j is [ __ ] amazing
that was that was dan again i don't know
the other guys i'm sure they're great i
just they roasted the [ __ ] out of me
bring up to see how old i look from that
sam adams commercial bring that up for a
second you do look younger bring it up
bring up that let's take a look at this
because
i was actually embarrassed and and big j
went on a i don't know a 20 minute rant
on me i need a sweater i'm cold
my teeth i don't know what he was doing
it was unbelievable
dude look at how old i am here holy [ __ ]
no bubba you got to see this in my
backyard
now you look very young i've gotten
younger you've gotten older adams
forced me to thank you well didn't force
me gave me a reason to i kind of like
that commercial but they we we're going
to hear it now you want to hear a chance
yeah hit it i thought you could do it
actual now we can do it being a comedian
is the greatest my basement
on earth real basement difficult job
check out the locks but iced fight grown
man are you fake riding there
this is a great commercial dude with sam
adams you think legacy the foundation of
what america is about the idea to toast
someone is important because there's so
much content these days in social media
i hope you're thinking
i'm drawing it's very real like can you
pretend you're like i can actually
acknowledge someone who actually matters
not through a tweet i'll throw a picture
on it
it's important to do something like this
no you look good but watch me
everybody's movie ends especially when
it comes to boxers or fighters who stick
around long enough everybody ends up
facing down butt up canvas there's no
longevity in it i'm on this rocky sea
and it's foggy and i don't know where
i'm going i'm lost and you know the
skanks guys they love sentiments you
would love telling me
yeah they played that too ari did it for
uh he was good in it i liked her i think
he did red band yeah aries was good they
would give him hard dollars if he
knocked me out and so he's this killer
and he walks in this gym and i start
making fun of him not mean but just kind
of roasting what he's wearing and how
big he is and brian goes you know you're
gonna do stand-up right i was like yeah
you're crazy but brian just kept
planting that seed it meant the world to
me the world
well no one's worth it smelling the
roses
and the two of us stopping and smelling
the roses the worst yeah i never do but
i wanted to stop and take a moment man
and cheers you because it's all my
favorite you saw something that i even
see in myself and since day one you've
pushed me to to get better and oh wow
you look stunning i'll stop that oh
[ __ ] go
back go back you look like clinton
currently now hold on did you weigh more
there too i don't know dude it looks
like a [ __ ] uh filter look at that
that's an old man filter that's how you
look dude bubba look at my eyes and now
that's like that's pretty
exhausted i was really tired and that's
pretty how heavy your like your your
your jowls but why is that was i holding
water hey hey hey hey that's how you
look though right
i like like we're pretending it was a
filter
come on don't say that hold on your face
looks a lot thinner right now it does
and i would say when you stay up too
much your fit you do retain water and
your cortisol levels okay maybe ate a
wheel of cheese i was under a lot of
stress i maybe ate a wheel of cheese and
drank a bottle of red wine one and then
showed up
which is 100 true i was living on cheese
and wine there and i had some rice is
all over my body sure and that's sick
this is a conspiracy theory and we'll
we'll run with that for now but you're
just old right
okay i want to get to into conspiracy
theories you know me i'm not a big
conspiracy guy but let's keep playing
okay play this and we're going to get to
some stuff so and they were lighting up
but
look at that
i called my plastic surgeon who did my
eyes i called him up yesterday
and i go jason my [ __ ] eyes and he
goes i told you dude people don't
realize until you see a before and after
picture yeah i go i look so much better
yeah he goes yep everybody thinks it
doesn't make a difference yeah i don't
think you're it's your eyes buddy it's
your your choice
keep playing keep playing it take a look
take a better look keep playing
and better
[Laughter]
000 years old
oh sorry is brendan toasting a mummy
we're trying not to laugh you remember
this brother yes yeah do you feel that
buttons are not enough or is this a
feature it's just kind of like oh
just makes me angry when you're that
fashionable for some reason
it's good
it's good enjoy your beer
boston lager do you try not to laugh
that's a great commercial great joe
coyze is probably we can't i think we
kept laughing didn't we oh yeah we did a
couple takes and i was just [ __ ]
laughing because that's a
the guy who directs that thing is theo's
boy and he's fantastic i forget his name
all right taking a quick break listen
guys if you like comedy san jose improv
this weekend thursday friday saturday
then i got uh spokane comedy club the
following weekend in spokane washington
or spokane whatever you want to call it
then i got tacoma washington in tacoma
and then i got bridgeport connecticut
october 13th 14th 15th at the stress
factory i'm going to read brendan's
dates because he's literally
he's just farted he's had he's lying
down he's got food poisoning he's in
ontario this weekend
ontario improv then he's in boston at
laugh boston september 29th 30th october
1st then he's at the san jose improv
october 13th the 15th salt lake city
wise guys october 20th to the 22nd and
now a quick word from our sponsor better
help now listen
guys you take care of your body you eat
well the problem is a lot of people
don't know how to take care of their
brain they don't have to take care of
their mood they don't know how to take
care of their mindset their mental state
mental illness is real even for people
who are usually fine it gets to you
depression lack of confidence
anxiety
malaise in general better help
is
a company that allows you to actually
get help from a licensed therapist
online okay you don't have to sit there
and worry about sitting in a in a
waiting room and meeting somebody you
can do this stuff online and therapy
take it from me works
it works sometimes you just don't know
how to find your way through problems
and talking about things can be very
helpful depending okay
better help is all about therapy it's a
great option it's convenient accessible
affordable and entirely online you get
matched with a therapist after filling
out a brief survey and you can switch
therapists at any time so when you want
to be a better problem solver therapy
can get you there visit
betterhelp.com
fighter there's no shame in this man
everybody needs help
betterhelp.com
fighter today to get 10 off your first
month that's
i'm
betterhelp.com
your boy
threw too much caffeine but here i am
sweating my
tail off right about to throw up hey the
nfl's opening week was action-packed my
broncos are terrible with bad coaching
but whatever get ready for week two of
touchdowns big plays and even bigger
wins with my friends at draftking
sportsbook an official sports betting
part of the nfl this week new customers
can bet just five dollars on any gaming
200 ruse and free bets instantly want
more action say less everyone can
experience the thrill of draftkings
early win promotion it's simple this
sunday bet on any nfl team to win if
your team leads by 10 at any point
during the game you get paid instantly
it's that easy even if they lose
fight fans we have corey sanhagen
fighting this saturday baby you have
triple g canelo bet on it make bank bro
don't forget about the highly
anticipated
fights coming up you got big ufc
pay-per-views download the draftking
sportsbook app
right now use promo code fighter to get
two hundred dollars in free bets
instantly when you place a five dollar
bet on any football game that's code
fighter only a draftking sports week an
official sports betting partner the nfl
minimum age eligibility restrictions
apply seashell notes for details see
next page for directions disclaimer
that's draftkings download it promo
codes fighter
but he's great i i'm sorry to change the
subject i i can't believe we got off the
top because i came here yeah you're
talking about the conspiracy theory of
you aging nope i'm not going to talk
about that
you bit of a rabble rouser
no you you bit of a rabble rouser what
happened
well hey hold on let me ask them what
happened you
read any news site well
yeah i got i got a lot of hey what
happened i got blasted apparently your
your boy provides a bug
he's stirring the pot a little bit he's
during the pa i'm
i'm you know what i'm doing my night
last night what are you doing i'm on i'm
about to it's shopping friends right now
slow down so it'll be cool yeah i'm
there with dalia era griffin please
don't do quiet practice but just tell me
i'm not so we're all chilling and then
my brother's like ah [ __ ] dana called
you a [ __ ] idiot and i'm like dana
called you a [ __ ] yeah if i get it
he's very to the point well his
vocabulary is hello what did you do what
did you do
like his vocabulary dude does it come
with [ __ ] seltzers what are you doing
dude you're such a broke are you rushing
for six months
no before you tell the story i don't i i
purposely stayed ignorant i just got a
bunch of clips dana calling
oh
and then
i didn't think it was much you know on
the shob show every monday i get on
there and because i've had how many
fights over 15 fights in the ufc i've
been in those um wins the weigh-in so
when he goes
when he goes oh it was uh so much chaos
and mayhem we have to shut down the
weigh-ins i watch i went
huh i bet the footage can be lit day
goes by nothing another day goes by
nothing after the fights i'm like
they're going to release some of it
nothing they release one like half-assed
video but it was weak so you're so then
so i was like let's just go through the
math here okay right
there's what are you saying there's i'm
so this is what i'm saying or are you
just asking questions i'm asking
questions so but here's my question
there's 26 fighters on the card on that
particular card each fighter gets
minimum two corner men so let's say two
to three if you have the main event you
can have five right and there's
basically two main events so that's if
they both have calculators so five times
four do you know so
so you know so you have 20 there
so 78 total but let's say you know the
main event so but and then you include
staff and security let's just round it
down to a nice number like a hundred
what those weigh-ins guys are bored as
[ __ ] everybody's on their phone to
entertain them and they're getting their
mind off the fight everybody's on their
phone so if there was
mayhem what would happen hold on no you
just put it in your quotes
you're already saying that no i'm just
saying no
mayhem so if there was mayhem for the
biggest ufc he that's never happened
before because oh there's never been
drama in the ufc also there's no
there's there's no camera crew at all
all then you're saying nobody has
cameras on their phone oh it's so weird
man so so to me when he said that all i
said is like i'm not a big conspiracy
guy if you want about jfk jfk jr
i'm your hucklebee you want to talk
about charles manson i read chaos i'm
your hucklebee outside that i don't
entertain the lizard people entertain
flat earth i don't contain a lot of this
[ __ ] but when it comes to that i just
have some questions you just ask them
questions and i'm a [ __ ] dummy well
well here's the thing here's the thing
you can't call another grown man a
[ __ ] dummy at a press conference and
i'm just going to lay back and be chill
because there's other things it's pretty
funny
it's
funny but also nothing there's something
about those there's something about when
you call somebody what you call somebody
when you were in middle school that
cracks me up like just going you're a
dumb you know what's funny about it is
he has 400 million dollars in the bank
and then still calls people [ __ ] dana
gets emotional dana's an emotional guy
right yeah sure we can you know try to
help him as much as we can and i get it
my thing is you know when
why don't they print all the stuff i say
good about when's the last one
heard me say something bad about him you
go ahead you because when he stuck up
for our buddy joe rogan i went you know
what and go ahead and play the [ __ ]
tape back for all the people that are
balls
i went you know what because what he did
for rogan it's not my story to tell i've
never told the story but i'm gonna quit
being so hard on dana i don't know how
the company goes you know so i'm gonna
quit nitpicking everything now you've
been you've been fair because you've
said a lot of times you said i don't
know what it's like to run the ufc so
for me to criticize dana yeah that's
insane he's being criticized right now
yeah i mean i can do it but still
brain surgery but also this is the game
we play
one negative thing but i don't think you
say anything negative it sounds to me
like so let me get what you're saying
and i said i said i went i went home in
the paint but also but let me get what
you're saying let me just stop you and
say your face bro you're saying dude i'm
a rapper because you're a girl you're a
rabble rouser i'm a rabble rouser you're
a rabble rapper yeah i'm all bunched up
now here's the thing you're basically
pretending it sounds like you're saying
this
i'll answer back but it sounds like
you're saying this it sounds like you're
saying
that kevin holland did not spartan kick
comes out chemical in the chest
you know you [ __ ] up right because
it's hamza spartan kids yes i'm sorry
i'm sorry
comes out carry on you're saying that
there wasn't a toss-up no not you're
saying this wasn't it and
there might have been words like words
there's words at everywhere and here's
travis brown okay and roy nelson had one
was my question they didn't shut the
[ __ ] fight here's my um let me ask
some questions can i ask a question
though yeah if everything i'm saying has
no
truth behind it
why so mad bro
why so man
if nothing ever happened you know how i
would have dealt with if i'm him if i'm
hitting my 400 million dollars in the
bank i'm mickey mouse i'll ask you go
ahead i'm at the press conference uh
next question a guy who i sing highly
pick so you don't uh bring up anything
controversial go
go
minion
hey go
low energy white minion
europe i don't identify as white anybody
else anybody else who doesn't subscribe
to every word i say
get out of it do you mind if i ask a
question i'm so sorry i went on a rant
what's your [ __ ] question
old man in the back what do you got
my question sir old wood face what do
you got
do you mind sir sorry i don't like these
ad hominem insults i'm so sorry that's
your stupid question uh brandon shop is
that just no brennan shop is suggesting
that
maybe there wasn't a toss-up and maybe
you're drumming up controversy
for
i don't know
clicks or something what now you know as
a good journal i'll answer that question
but as a good journalist you should ask
really
what exactly brendan shop said do your
due diligence before you open up what
did you say before you open up your fat
red trap what did you say what did i say
oh i said fat lit red fat red trap
all i said was i have some questions and
the chance of it being big conspiracy
all right but the chance of that's not
good and also i get his his argument
about the commission stuff like that all
i'm saying is that some questions
because for this to work out exactly
like it did everything would have to
come in line you you take the nate diaz
out of the fight right and
so it just so how it works out where
hamzad's finding a 180 pound man right
and he's just having to weigh 180 pounds
and then uh holland weighs in at a
catchweight 180 he's never done that
before so i'm already there i'm like no
that's weird but i'll roll with it
because i'm a team player i'm like what
would be the so he fights harlan at 180
and it's a perfect matchup for hamza
you're hold on hamzad who's a [ __ ]
monster wrestler against guy who has no
wrestling okay i'll play that game let's
keep playing that game so then if i did
my due diligence where i'm going to take
a backhand to my employees when i get
back from this here's my thing
he got so upset because i questioned
what exactly happened right now his only
defense is how you know people lying
it's a it's a page out of his buddy
trump's book which i
actually like the way he argues and
debates people i think it's hilarious
it's very bro-ish of him but it's funny
so i like funny right so when dana when
he attacks me he doesn't address my main
point i'm not talking about he goes well
to say that this was a a low trending
pay-per-view we sold the arena sold out
the gate was sold out hey
red face
i'm not talking about the gate okay you
sold out whatever the arena was at
t-mobile that's easy work jay leno could
[ __ ] sell that out you sell out every
show that's not a big deal it's whatever
16 000 people i'm not talking about that
i'm referring to and this way [ __ ] up
bro i'm referring to the trending
pay-per-views because they know how
pay-per-view is gonna do before it even
uh before the first prelims fight on
saturday they have an idea how it's
gonna do
based off the algorithm the media all
the marketing they put into it they have
an idea
my theory again i'm not dying on this
hill i'm i'm definitely not dying this
hill but we'll get to how i can validate
my theory my theory is it wasn't
trending well because the treatment of
nate diaz a legend of ufc a guy who's
put his life on the line a guy who's
always fought the man wanted out of his
contract has demanded a fight for a year
now and you won't give it to him and
because he wanted to go off and venture
and fight jake paul make all more money
than god than dana's ever paid him you
make him walk through this [ __ ]
terrible matchup that most fans the
general fans
they're not familiar with them yeah but
they look up the odds and they go holy
oh this is a slaughter this is the scene
of jurassic park where the t-rex eats
the [ __ ] chained up goat we don't
want to see this so it's not trending so
dana overplayed his hand you see he
overplayed his hand yesterday it was a
genius way of getting out of it so he
goes this ain't good man and also he
didn't realize
the support nate diaz has now you can be
a nate diaz hater a nick dsater the diaz
brother haters you can be a hater but
you know when somebody's being a bully
and [ __ ] somebody over and he thought
ah people won't care they just want to
see homs i get a win we don't
we actually don't we actually care more
about nate diaz than hamzlot and the
treatment of him we're not [ __ ] with
it and if you remember the wednesday
before that pay-per-view what i say on
this that [ __ ] nate diaz rant i went
on i said this why i should root for
nate diaz and i said if you're actually
a nate diaz fan and you want to show
that you're not okay with this don't buy
the pay-per-view now i'm not saying that
influence people not buying the
pay-per-view but i'm saying that's one
way you can fight the man and fight back
it's the only thing you can do so i
think it wasn't trending well they came
up with this theory and it was their
plan b all along it just happened to
work out i got a catch weight at 180 is
very strange because it wasn't that
short no notice of a fight tony ferguson
beyond the tony friction ideas makes
all the sense all the sense so that just
happens to be the perfect matchup again
that's i'm fine with that maybe the
stars aligned and that happened for you
that's more likely than not what
happened i'm all good with that all i'm
saying is is for the first time the ufc
you cancel wayne because of the
chaos air quotes but where's the footage
of that because i have questions
i'll get to your uh old weathered man in
the back listen oh just a second sir i'm
not done so it with all that chaos right
go through the timeline in ufc history
when there's chaos
let's talk about it and when not only
were there khabib on here well so we'll
get the you you jumped the gun there so
not only during conor's uh
tear when he threw the [ __ ] dolly
through the [ __ ] bus window with
their cameras there was a entire crew
john jones no hold on
[ __ ] up [ __ ] uh [ __ ] a cell phone there
was crow a ufc camera crew now
in order for
conor mcgregor to fly in a private plane
with his goons
land where they were at and get access
to that bus
you can't do that it doesn't work like
that staged or at least very strange i
feel like somebody knew what was up oh
oh you don't think connor tweeted or
text dana or some [ __ ] something maybe
he did
but
to me like now what's more likely
a camera crew and cameras are around to
capture that footage when connor random
randomly appears and throws a dolly
through a [ __ ] bus window and we get
every angle several angles it probably
took them hours to edit that thing they
had so many angles what's more likely
the case of that
or at the ufc weigh-in where that they
cancel the [ __ ] weigh-ins because
there was so much
did they cancel the weigh-ins of the
press conference press conference past
conference uh so
i have a question but does that make
sense to me do you not have some
questions and also if i'm a [ __ ]
dummy if i read off the list of names
this is my best sebastian impression if
i ran off a list of names
who have called and text me to support
my theory
it would blow your mind yeah now did me
and jake paul talk this morning yeah i'm
of course saying that all right did he
leave a comment of course he likes this
stuff i don't do this stuff in general i
try to just i try to keep it positive
keep it moving i have a question i keep
it positive keep it moving i ask a
question when you tug on the tail of the
big thick lion well sometimes i got an
answer yeah daddy never punches down i'm
never gonna punch down no yeah there's
some low-level comic to fire shots at me
i get it i'm a comic it's a nightmare
i'd be i'd hate me too it's not fair
it's not my fault don't don't hold on
i'm not i'm just saying i would hate me
too i get that stuff because comedy's
such a hard [ __ ] round yeah and when
other like journalists would ever come
at me all good dude i'm not going to
play that game i'm not in the business
of gossip and negativity
look at my [ __ ] track record i agree
but when you're a little bit of a rabble
rabbit but well
but you're going to tuck on the whole
thick lines table well you
i like your questions i didn't talk
first i liked your questions
no you didn't because you were just
asking questions you could bring dana
into it not and then but you didn't
bring dana into it you were just asking
the ufc in general i had some questions
but then when he goes on that uh when
he's at that press conference after uh
the dana white contender series which
where he did it and he wants to call me
a [ __ ] dummy but before that he had a
whole rant on pat milicek because he got
confused he thought
pat had the same theory as i did which
apparently he did that's the part i saw
but i didn't know what was it yeah and
this someone goes uh one of the minions
in the back who uh is approved to be
there goes that's actually that i was
wasn't quoting pat that's actually
brendan schaub and he goes that makes
more sense yes and smile so that's what
i saw so his rant after all that which
was dr directed towards a legend he
should be
sucking his toes minimum sucking his
totes you don't shame a guy like that
become a [ __ ] idiot
excuse me sir he's great you know what
time he do do you pioneer now hold on
keep that same energy if you saw him in
person it's about i would be scared of
pat military he's a savage but also he's
earned the right to question and ask
questions i've earned the right to ask
those questions
now if you're just some joe schmoe
journalist who's never risked it you
know in the octagon
you have no right to ask those questions
well you can ask questions you can you
can but there's his job there's no
validation behind it but when you've
been in there and you're like oh and
i've been in i don't know over at least
12 to 15 times in the back of that room
i know exactly how it works i go that's
strange even back then i've never been a
big cell phone guy but i would have
recorded the melee and then so i have a
question what's your stupid here's my
question
why
why would are you saying that comes out
and kevin holland made that story up
because they didn't come out and deny it
oh
is that a naive question yeah they're
just asking questions hey they're cogs
in the machine
so in other words they're cogs in the
machine so they're going to keep it
quiet because they might have been part
of the
drama
with tom's lot and all that stuff and
with nate diaz right
i don't think the ufc is privy to alert
them on what's going on they're making
moves and acting like someone oh my god
we're gonna have to do this and like
okay here's the other thing
when so we should take dana at word
right you want to take dana that word
he's never lied to us well he just lied
in the in the previous post fight press
conference because people go um dana did
you compensate these guys since you
switched opponents on 24 hour no seos we
didn't compensate anybody
well and then these journalists who a
lot of them i do respect i'm just making
jokes here a lot of my due respect
what dane doesn't realize these
journalists who are good journalists
every fighter that went through who won
right or lost but most of the guys that
one they have on there every single one
of them dana said that i went cool say
less every single one of them were you
compensated more of course they're going
no because they're in on it no no no no
nate diaz goes oh they paid me so much
money i didn't know how much it
was so we know for a fact you're lying
about fighter compensation and now other
fighters come and go yeah we actually
got commentary because they shuffled the
card
but hold on dana question here question
so
you told us you didn't compensate those
guys but you actually did
so you lied about that and so is it
extreme for brendan schaub who's been
nothing but supportive because you're
because what you did for rogan nothing
but supportive i i haven't talked to i
haven't brought fighter paid but now
you're tugging on the thick lines tail
so now i gotta bring up where it hurts
your mouse i gotta talk about fighter
pay i've been cool about it i've been
great about it now you're not well well
if you got me a [ __ ] dummy yeah well
now you got my attention
[ __ ] face right
right and also i got nothing to do daddy
so i'm gonna put
i got nothing to do i was muzzled when i
was working for a certain corporation
but now i decided to venture off on my
own baby bird this thick bird grew his
wings and now i'm not muscled there's no
consequences
so the other thing is is if you try to
silence me or stop fighters from coming
on my shows i don't give a [ __ ] i made
it despite your dumb ass
right yeah so if so in some funny world
you're able to take down all my fight
shows my life doesn't change
i talk just talk about fighting because
i enjoy the fight game but if it went
away i don't give a [ __ ] okay so you're
dealing with a crazed man here
okay
yeah
you're a little crazy and you got
nothing to lose and you look like you're
ready i'm drinking on i'm sipping all
the punch you look like i've had the
punch and someone spiked it
now i drank that dana white pudding i'm
gonna put my tin i'm gonna put my
tinfoil hat on you've been talking a
long time so i want to just encapsulate
what i think you're saying recap it and
don't [ __ ] it up think what you're
saying i got my tin foil hat on go ahead
all right i'm i'm channeling sam tripoli
i'm channeling eddie bravo right now and
they both agree with me with karen now
hold on
that will
make your dick shrivel up sir i i'm sure
let's let's bleep out sean strickland's
number two no no no no no sean
strickland is on record me and sean did
not talk i'm a fan of sean okay he came
out on record on his podcast or on
instagram was like i just want to get
anything in trouble no
that's out there okay i would not i'm
i'm smarter than that but but
so so i'm going to put my tinfoil hat on
i want to encapsulate this whole thing
you are saying
dana white got mad at at nate said you
don't want to you don't want to play
ball you're going to walk through chess
and fire all of a sudden he starts
getting crazy
uh hate over that and realizes that he
is
out over his toes and that's not a good
look and it's going to be hard to walk
remember
you're a little over your skis and a
little over your skis and by the way
your your pay-per-view numbers are not
trending to the degree you wanted him to
and that might be very well because
people don't want to see a legend have
to walk through that check and fire it's
not fun i couldn't have said it better
myself okay now
then then the genius idea would be
why don't
that we we talk about this melee
backstage
which is komzat kevin holland got into
it so bad i had to actually cancel the
[ __ ] press conference now we go damn
that's the first time that's ever
happened this must be these guys must
have tried to kill each other how much
hype did he get and then we all go oh
[ __ ] and i i remember saying i want to
see kevin holland there you go and comes
out because they're because kevin's
bigger they're more sized they fight
they fought at 185 gotcha
no but they they both used to bite at 85
before they went down to 70. so they've
got a big frame hook line single yeah
that's all they're doing
then
can i just see can i just say so you're
spot on so far hammer set and keep going
i don't mean interrupt you the only
caveat there is
this wasn't something that was planned
on friday night
this card was designed just in case they
got so much backlash
this was a plan b just in case we have
to pull the emergency brake which they
have to do got it carry on so now so now
uh the the
they say listen
they got in a fight you know what let's
get those two to fight each other
because comes out missed weight anyway
he's at 80. kevin's in 80. it makes more
sense he missed weights we don't want to
fight him nate because now he's way
bigger it's not fair
by the way tony's right here
i mean let's put him in the comments
because they're about the same tony's
first time at 170. what a great swans
worked out so well great swan song so
great if this is true then i think dana
white's a genius because that's genius
move right there
his staff could probably whatever yeah
somebody's [ __ ] genius somebody's
working i mean ufc keeps making money
and growing so [ __ ] whoever's doing
it no argument there okay
so so so gun to your head
percentage-wise how true do you think
that theory is how how much
yes
30
30
okay that's respectable kept in the way
why why now it would be zero percent if
they showed me footage it would be zero
percent if they release pay-per-view
numbers now now here's the other
question so they it would be zero
percent if he wasn't caught lying
multiple times so you think somebody
whispered and comes out here to say miss
wait
because we got a plan and see that's
where that that's where if i'm
watching this and listen to my theory
like come on you think a chest names can
be in on this
the only thing that strange me is play
ball as is how and play ball and also
you're going to be the dark knight of
the ufc and and being the evil villain
because he got booed right yeah
he goes i don't give a [ __ ] yeah no he's
really fine
dana's fine with it dana's most recent
statement goes anyone who thinks hamlet
had a bad week is an idiot let's just go
over track record there's nothing worse
you can do as a professional fighter
nothing is more unprofessional he gets
so mad dana freaks out people you go
back to tough you go back to tough and
[ __ ] tough
dude people
aren't lose their jigs yes he was dana's
happy about it humslap's happy about it
all i'm saying is i got questions and
then you come out and your recent press
conference go homeside had a great week
that's in the history that you see has
never happened when a guy missed week
would miss wait ever
ever
all i'm saying i get some questions i'm
liking and i'm a [ __ ] dumb i like
your questions i like your questions
because now i got questions now i got
questions
well now i got questions i don't even
have a dog in this fight nom
you got me like this now i'm like well
we did we had am i wrong but hold on but
also you try to find
some footage
can i see some footage oh show the
footage chin that they showed before
they did on the uc pay-per-view yeah
that was a lead into it they showed
footage you tell me if it was melee and
then they showed the footage at the
hotel of darren taylor and kevin holland
oh you mean two gentlemen talking it out
where's the melee you want melee melee
is jon jones [ __ ] dc fighting each
other in las vegas at a press conference
that's melee now did uh
i wonder if [ __ ] um
oh here we go
interviews now say something huh
everyone like playing dragsters now come
on come here
so he throws a water bottle
never seen water bottle frozen
oh cause connor didn't throw
rain energy drinks before
i think i think it's a genius way of
getting out of uh you got to deal with i
think if somebody because people were
biting they're like oh they showed the
footage
that is nothing that's nothing we've
seen way worse and that's all i'm saying
if there was no track record of this if
if this is the definition of melee then
i'm like all right yeah all right
apparently we've seen a lot worse and
we've i mean they showed they showed in
the official promos
the dolly throw and everything so
there's it's not like they have a
boundary about showing the highlands no
it has nothing no how about the clip of
homeboy in the middle of dc and jon
jones when they're
falling off the stage punching each
other in the face yeah
did they cancel that fight no they
didn't
press conference right yeah
um
uh i'm i'm i'm now i'm at all i'm saying
is you got me asking questions probably
a lot of people and can i know that can
you read that list off and we'll just
bleep it out and i won't read no because
you know i don't i don't i don't want to
[ __ ] here's the thing i'm not here to
here's the other thing i don't give a
[ __ ] yeah if this is what you guys did
it's fun fantastic it's fun and it's
actually a good theory
it's not bad there's some
there's some grounds to it but again all
i'm asked you know how you should have
dealt with it if i'm dana and i have 400
on bank and mickey mouse is my boss you
know what i do and joe rogan's on the
[ __ ] uh
[ __ ] boost t-mobile [ __ ] i can just
call him whenever that's my boy and
donald trump and we're
sharing diet cokes and [ __ ] you know and
i'm on trt you know what i do if i'm
dana i would if someone goes yeah shop
thinks this i go
i get that it is insane it's not no i i
i go i can't believe we were able to
pull that off from his perspective who
and his perspective yeah he fought her
but he didn't know the inner work ends
up on matchups together with the
commission and don't even start on the
the [ __ ] the commission the [ __ ]
shady commission so that doesn't hold up
that's too much yeah i would have said
so i would have said
so
listen i get it he fought here he's
going to do great things he don't know
what the [ __ ] he's talking about when it
comes to running the business of the ufc
but from his optics and from others i've
heard this theory before
we're not that smart there's no way
there's no way it wouldn't happen but i
can see how he says that it's just not
true move on
to shade a legend pat milchik and pat's
you know pat's not on doesn't have a mic
like this or maybe does a pocket maybe
not at this level and then pat's on
instagram pat's older
so you want to be a bully
well i'm not going to put up with that i
can't have that you're not going to
shade pat millchick and mean the same
sentence and then just cruise around in
your ferrari in newport i can't have
that
i got to say something daddy do you know
what i think is the most likely scenario
they did get in a tusk up backstage and
then they said this is a great
opportunity to get out of this quest
that's where that's right they probably
went man this thing's not i stick to my
theory that was not trending well yes i
stick my theory that the the general fan
base went this is [ __ ] up what they're
doing tonight tony ferguson and nate wow
it blew up in his face yeah and then
kevin holland to your theory kevin
holland hamza got into it tony's there
and dana's sitting back going
this actually helps us because we can
ride on this which is brilliant whoever
decide to do that whether it's dana or
one of the staff members that's
brilliant the fights are actually better
because of this that's why i really
don't have a dog in the fight i don't
give a [ __ ] no
fighters
genius not fighters not fighters here's
the other thing you're gonna wear those
new rock under armour shoes and not be
compensated and shut your yapper all
right that's what you guys are gonna do
and no one's gonna say [ __ ] that's the
other problem i have with it yeah
so you're tugging on the tail and i have
nothing to lose daddy yeah
fighters are still not as far as you're
concerned getting compensated the way
they should excuse me and i've been cool
about it
but again if you call me a [ __ ] idiot
as a grown man well come on dude do you
have an idea of what these guys are
making which ones
which ones from top to bottom yeah i
have an idea you do yeah yeah
of course i do and and uh the champions
are fine champions are compensated but
remember that in order to make a change
those champions have to go
again they're fat and happy but they
think they're getting a big percentage
they're actually not if they realize
their actual worth they'd be [ __ ]
shouting from the rooftops for for more
money but dana's brilliant in that part
going i'm gonna take care of the guys
that could actually make the change so
they shut the [ __ ] up like you the one
thing about nate diaz who's talked all
this [ __ ] about the ufc he's never
talked about fight or pay he takes care
of nate because nate's on filter nada
come out and light you up yeah he'll
light you up you're gonna take care of
that he's always spoken and he has an
army behind him trust me i've been in
tussle with him you don't want to be in
a tubs with him he has a massive
audience so if you compensate the guys
who actually movers and shakers
the rest of the guys don't they don't
have any leverage it's brilliant and i
don't know to be fair i don't know if
i'd run the ufc any different
well
i've been trying to run a company like
that there are so many hidden details
that we'd all have a very different
perspective probably you know until
you've done it you it's hard to be yeah
but let's not act like he's [ __ ] it's
brainstorming let's take it a little
easy because the one match up he listen
the people who are the movers and
shakers the fc that make the match-ups
are mick maynard and [ __ ] uh uh sean
shelby those are the guys that have to
go through the prelims of the main card
then the main event dana will chime in
the one time he actually got his pick
which the [ __ ] over nate diaz was hamza
nate diaz that's a terrible idea and it
blew up in your face all good especially
when nate this one didn't work out when
nate did that interview and said i
didn't ask for this fight it's not weird
now because oh weird it's like dana lied
again because he told us nate asked for
the fight but then as soon as you put a
mic in front of nate's face he goes i
didn't ask for this fight i don't want
this fight i'm trying to get to jake
paul but they're making me do this
so who who do you believe in that
nate who's not a liar or dana who the
history shows time over time or time is
a [ __ ] con artist those are facts
now he's done some great stuff and
sometimes you got to be that way to be
in his shoes so again i don't fault them
for that i've been nothing but
complimentary of that guy but that never
makes the news man
that would that's the algorithm of the
world we live in now negative like this
guy you think i like doing this
you think i like this gossip [ __ ] no
man i got [ __ ]
five shows in ontario thursday friday
saturday
no i'm but i'm saying like that's my
focus yeah not dana i'll be in san jose
if you guys want to talk about it it
won't be this friday there's no drama
there well but maybe i'll bring some
drama
drama maybe i got inside you've got 30
minutes on dana white you're going to
roast you never know
what what i'm trying to achieve when
this stuff comes it's like it's like
that nap when you're at a [ __ ]
barbecue like get out of here come on
dude i'm trying to eat my ribs my ribs
are comedy man i'm focused on that and
it's [ __ ] tough dude yeah so this
stuff i don't give a [ __ ]
but if you're but if you're gonna poke
the bear
you're not era hawaiian and the reason
why i didn't mean when me and ariel went
into it i respect ariel i really do i
think he's the best we have i know he's
amazing and what happened to ariel
because he didn't when they asked to
jump he went hold on well how high right
they [ __ ] them they shunned them off
the island and they only have people yes
men surrounded by them why don't you get
down with that i root for aerial man
even though we've had our issues i root
for ariel i want him and he is he's the
biggest show in the space thank god i
root for ariel but the rest of the guys
that he's voted off the island who
aren't the the success stories of ariel
and myself it [ __ ] sucks man and
that's who we're fighting for it's
[ __ ] up dude and these fighters who
text me please don't say anything but
please don't say anything but
please don't say anything but i have
this information i would never out them
because i know it's going to affect
their bottom dollar kids and fans of
course not
so it's like all right dude there's a
great deal all right
yes and i'm in boston in two weeks
dana's hometown now did i blast out the
tickets on instagram story and say oh
interesting hey any fighters been [ __ ]
over by dana white or dana white family
members that he's [ __ ] over tickets on
the house swipe up
yeah i did
that's
that's gratuitous that's hilarious
that's pretty good guys
san jose free tickets
no just come by san jose improv this
weekend starting tomorrow yeah i don't
like that and you like i love it
personally i love it you and rogan love
this beef well no i love it because i i
think it's i think it's a really fun
question i think it's a really fun
[ __ ] conspiracy theory
i think that um
if if here's what i like about your
theory
if you went to dana
and said dana listen come over here i
think i have a plan of a way out of this
this
this drama this hate that you're getting
over this terrible matchup for nate diaz
no one approved this fight but i mean no
one left and if you went to him with
that it'd be really tempting to embrace
it that's a [ __ ] great idea yeah
that's what somebody could fight yeah
that's probably what they did well you
have to do is put those guys together
close get them close to each other
they'll start mouthing off ufc if that's
your business you know the [ __ ] that
kevin holland was talking to hamza so
you're gonna put them next to each other
of course it's like it's two [ __ ]
pitbulls and also that card you're
dealing on that card specifically you
look at the lineup especially the the
the to the four main fighters in the
main event co-main event you're talking
about
sat
street savages
who they don't play by the same rules as
the others where if you talk [ __ ]
they're gonna say something we all i
don't work for the ufc and i'd be like
oh we gotta make sure we separate these
guys
they know and if i if i know this yeah
they know this i i
i had i couldn't help but to wonder what
nate would have done with comsat's
wrestling because nate is
very right it would have been a [ __ ]
disaster okay and that's why i didn't
trend well yeah because that's why
because even his wrestling is just too
much everything's too much yeah nothing
would have worked it'd been a [ __ ]
night that [ __ ]
again it's not fair it's [ __ ] up to do
to a guy who's paid his dues and then
you give him this [ __ ] chest name
killer the hottest
prospect we've had in since jon jones
how dare you man and the the general
fans answered back i'm like no no no no
no no who's who comes out fighting next
colby at 170.
how do you feel about that fight tough
fight for colby yeah but with his cardio
and stuff like that you know we'll see
what happens it's a much better matchup
than nate and [ __ ]
you've been with both of them he's
bigger than kobe right oh yeah taller
yeah
and kobe's tenacity his wrestling we'll
see if he gets tired is it good it's a
way way better matchup colby's an
underdog in that fight probably a plus
220 i'd imagine right but he's not a
plus whatever 2200
that's when fans go you remember how
upset people were when mike tyson you'd
uh sit down for a pay-per-view and he
would knock the guy on 17 seconds people
asked for their money back if people
don't want that [ __ ] they want a good
fight man will we see comsat fight leon
before leon fights camaro no no no no
no because it ruins the the rubber match
between camaro and leon because it's a
good because again leon would be an
underdog
so then you [ __ ] that you [ __ ] your nut
on camaro leon i don't know i mean i
don't know what and hamza you can't give
hamzat a title shot after beating right
kevin holland it doesn't work like that
he shouldn't got a tough fight even if
he beat nate diaz it doesn't work like
that you knew i mean you can see kevin
yeah asking daniel and he trains aka
teach me how to wrestle daniel like in
the middle of his fight yeah like he's
he's you knew that that's probably what
was going to happen nightmare of a
matchup yeah i didn't think you would
submit them that fast kevin hall is a
black belt no i don't think he is he's
black i don't believe that's true bring
it up nick i don't believe kevin holland
is a black belt
hell of an athlete and punch is so
[ __ ] hard
he's been fighting for he's been
fighting for a minute but second
putting kung fu oh yeah black belt in
brazilian jiu jitsu
oh [ __ ] it's so weird like i know what
i'm talking about all right any other
questions from the media second degree
good good black belt dude travis lew
there's no punk you have a black belt or
travis looter you know and you know your
way around the ground and that didn't
matter with coms out no
he [ __ ] dark stroke though kevin
haunt's a legit black belt dude dude
[ __ ] you keep saying he's a good athlete
i hate that no no no
he hits [ __ ] yeah but he but he his
his background is he's dedication for a
long time he's a good [ __ ] fighter i
thought he had no wrestling and i
thought he was he has no wrestling he
has but he's a black belt on the ground
he's a grappler remember he he what he
did the [ __ ] jockery from the guard
punch chakra and knocked him out from
his back still crazy still like he's a
little decorated like he's a legit black
belt [ __ ]
[ __ ]
what do you do with kamza what do you do
with anybody from cheshire dagestan
to to add more fire to my theory
dana for the first time ever in the
history of dfc goes yeah hams not missed
weight but for anybody saying a bad week
is insane that guy killed it
what not mad
not mad oh if my series my way out
i think i think he saw miss wade and he
was this is my way out or somebody got
in comps house here and say hey you can
miss wait don't worry about it it's
gonna be fine we got something for you
yeah cause people weren't texting me
that they saw mouth tonight before
drinking and eating anyway uh what else
you got i love these
questions see but but i'm a [ __ ]
dummy so i'm talking about i mean people
are in your ear
legit peeps oh yeah i know i'm talking
and he was out eating and drinking the
night before i'm talking like legit
journalists yeah now who knows maybe
they're full of [ __ ] i don't know i
don't talk about that stuff i don't give
a [ __ ] you were a little disparaging of
the journalists in the room do you want
to take that back no not at all no no no
i thought you respected them i thought
no only certain ones only not all of
them no not all i don't know anything a
lot of them are dating a lot of them
what did you say
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no we don't hear that [ __ ] no no um
no i respect a lot of the journalists um
certain ones i don't they're in his
pocket and won't ask the quest you know
when the white house when they toss up
softballs yeah and you can't have like
real legitimacy i didn't know that he
had purified the president oh yeah yeah
oh yeah he he was that a fact or are you
just
fact okay when i tell you stuff brother
yeah i'm [ __ ] telling you dude yeah
when i say kevin holland's a black belt
he's a [ __ ] black belt yeah when i
tell you people have been blacklisted
because they black balls from that room
yes when when they when they're asking
the wrong questions
what they think is wrong
you know and then and then also in one
word i didn't know he could do that i
i'm not well they run the they run the
company look at aaron hewani they pulled
his credentials he can't step foot in
the [ __ ] arena and why
and why because he was asking he's also
the best we have he's the most brilliant
guy we have you wanna blacklist that guy
why though oh because he's not gonna
give us softball questions you biden
you're mine
you're mine
like the inflation thing you see
inflation he wants to celebrate the
inflation are you out of your [ __ ]
mind dude
and then no one in the rooms i'm like
well actually this isn't good you're a
rabble rouser but i'm liking it but it's
facts though isn't it and you're a
little bit of a crazy man too because
you got i drink all the punch
i drink all the punch daddy
i don't ask for this now just go away
quietly and take your it's just that you
got called the dumbass and that's mean
and that got you a little bit well and
then he was taking a nap bullied a
legend pat milicic right he bullied him
and then he came at me and he came at me
yeah you know so it's like all right
dude i can't let you get away with both
of them also don't go for pat send that
send that energy towards me daddy yeah
i'll light you up yeah with your frat
bro vocabulary yeah well this isn't
gonna go well his biggest comeback is
[ __ ] dummy okay
okay is that your dinner white
impression
okay
does it come with a white claw every
time you say that who talks like that
how can you be that agent speak like
that who [ __ ] with that stuff yeah
you're surrounded by guys that aren't
smarter than you that's the [ __ ]
problem
but again he's done a great job
i have no issues with it yoski's making
money keeps growing sure right sure
funded by mickey mouse no watch it
hey the nfl's opening week was
action-packed my broncos are terrible
with bad coaching but whatever get ready
for week two of touchdowns big plays and
even bigger wins with my friends at
draftking sportsbook an official sports
betting part of the nfl this week new
customers can bet just five dollars on
any gaming 200 ruse and free bets
instantly want more action say less
everyone can experience the thrill of
draftkings early win promotion it's
simple this sunday bet on any nfl team
to win if your team leads by 10 at any
point during the game you get paid
instantly it's that easy even if they
lose fight fans we have corey sandhagen
fighting this saturday baby you have
triple g canelo bet on it make bank bro
don't forget about the highly
anticipated
fights coming up you got big ufc
pay-per-views download the draftking
sportsbook app right now use promo code
fighter
to get 200 in free bets instantly when
you place a 5 bet on any football game
that's code fighter only a draftking
sports week an official sports betting
partner the nfl minimum age eligibility
restrictions apply seashell notes for
details see next page for direction of
disclaimer that's draftkings download it
promo codes fighter
so guys everybody suffers from sexual or
erectile dysfunction sometimes and when
i say everybody i'm not talking about me
but some people do it's a very common
thing there's no shame in it a lot of
guys especially as you get older even
when you're younger
and there are all kinds of products to
help you essentially open up your blood
vessels and relax your body well
joy mode
is you don't want to be going to the gas
station and getting a pill you know
nothing about okay and people do this
all the time it's very tempting but
there are also products on the market
that claim to help men in bed you know
but you want a four-hour erection you
want nasty side effects hard problems
okay
a possible trip to the hospital to get
rid of that thing that's kind of how it
happens to well joy mode is essentially
a sexual performance booster
like a pre-workout but for sex okay
so here's how it works it's got joy mode
makes natural science-backed sexual
wellness products for men okay
and the sexual performance boosters
designed to support erection quality and
firmness now i'm going to read this
because this is this is what they have i
want to be very specific contains
clinically supported doses of
l-citrulline argonine yohimbe vitamin c
okay
look that up the scientists had their
biochemistry phds
so after taking the sexual performance
booster blood levels of argonne and
yohimbe will increase which will
directly promote nitric oxide production
penile tissue relaxation and increased
drive and i guess the nitric oxide
actually opens up your blood vessels
easier to get an erection blah blah blah
the antioxidant action of vitamin c
protects the nitric nitric oxide and
oxidative degeneration don't know i'm
not a scientist that enhances blood flow
promoting activity of nitric oxide
collectively these effects enhance sex
drive and blood flow to the penis
resulting in better performance created
because the products on the market are
terrible and they knew they could do
better prescriptions come with all sorts
of side effects and over-the-counter gas
station pills are sketchy and fraudulent
okay so here's how you take it you
basically drink it with eight ounces of
water it's like your favorite
electrolyte pack okay so for best use
consume anywhere within 45 minutes to
four hours prior to sexual activity let
us know what you think try this out now
i'm tempted let us know what you think
you want to spice things up in the
bedroom boost your sexual performance
and do it naturally without nasty
prescription drugs
fighter and kid audiences get if you go
to use joy mode dot com slash fighter
enter fighter at checkout for 20 off
your first order so so again
use
fighter and a joymode.com
for 20 off let us know what you think
i'm curious so some of the uh most uh
high functioning people i know
take alpha brain
they take
uh on its flagship supplement it's a
nootropic
okay you know there are times you're
doing what you think you know and you
can't think about anything else you're
in flow state okay it's when you're the
most focused you're the most productive
psychologists call that the feeling of
being in the zone
flow state people have written books on
this
alpha brain from on it is the ultimate
way
to actually get there when it comes to
supplements it's a nootropic supplement
it's got they've sold over a million
bottles okay again the creators of
on it the creators of the company
i have seen personally take alpha brain
before every podcast with my own eyes
and they would take it every single day
that gives me a lot of confidence in
this promotes cognitive functions
including memory mental speed focus
they've got double blind studies to
prove that
it can help you remember names here on a
complex task think more clearly under
stress
uh rogan
every time he does a podcast he takes it
um contains amino acids compounds that
promote the brain's release of alpha
waves which are associated with greater
creativity and productivity uh caffeine
free all right that's always a good
thing and by the way if you don't like
it for any reason if you don't like
alpha brain you can get your money back
give them two weeks at that point you
don't feel like alpha brain is fit for
you just tell them why and they will
refund your money on the spot no return
necessary save ten percent on your order
by going on it dot com slash f a t k
that's on it dot com slash f f-a-t-k
uh and if you don't do that swing by
your local walmart pick up some today
give it a shot exactly four weeks ago i
signed the inflation reduction act into
law so today we're celebrating tune in
at three there's no celebration dude so
this eight percent inflation dude
because of inflation the average
american they lose an entire paycheck
in a single month out of 12 months
that's entire [ __ ] paycheck you know
how bad that [ __ ] people over do you
know what uh here's a here's a [ __ ]
quick trivia question
do you know what most geostrategists
geopolitical experts
will tell you is the biggest threat
to china's development to china's future
uh population control yes
but it's population control but what do
you mean by that they're not having
enough kids thank you yeah that's
exactly right the fact that they don't
have
enough young people to support their
aging population and their economy
correct and so that's a major problem
you didn't think i knew that no you
didn't think this [ __ ] dummy knew
that i liked that bubba you know what
because i read a book
yeah dude like that inflation you know
uh grocery price is up 13 and a half
percent and you want to celebrate well
fertilizer is because of the natural gas
coming from rush has been
shut off or at least
really badly reduced even though
russia's making a billion dollars a day
still
uh it you need all that that natural gas
for things like fertilizer and all kinds
of stuff it's a [ __ ] so
interesting crude oil
uh it's gonna be a really interesting
time in the next two years the united
states apparently will be way better
than
we're we're lucky we're [ __ ] lucky
because a lot of the rest of the world
is going to have a really hard time yeah
england germany big problems like really
big because the queen died
because the queen was holding it
together sure access to oil access to
research
who's the the king taking over king
charles is it king charles used to be
prince charles you ever seen the dick
beaters on that man his hands yeah his
big old bratwurst hands
now just through scientific evidence and
this isn't a conspiracy if you have big
fingers like that those big digits
you're going to be packing an
absolute hammer it's got dick no those
are very swollen fingers
those are his hands though he's got some
kind of a swole swelling going on that's
a swelling yeah swelling of his dick
brian yeah no that's a swelling look at
those big hands
those are thick fingers imagine getting
a wet willy from that dude well dude
when i got uh when i got my checkup and
i had to check my [ __ ] uh prostate
the guy had those fingers
one digit one digit knuckle deep was
that the guy who was married to princess
diana damn it thank god we've all gotten
older
yeah but he's not young he won't be in
power
those are some thick hands
they look crazier like right there
though yeah go down
that's brian in the sam adams commercial
that's me and the sam adams commercial
that's an actual picture
his hands are he dude he has the same
hands as homer simpson
some big [ __ ] dick beaters yeah
there's some royal dick beaters yeah
yep
but again you're out your mind it's
science dude this isn't a conspiracy if
you have big hands
i'm worried about
ukraine and nukes i'm worried that the
russians are going to be put into a
corner and the only way out is either
withdraw
or light somebody up with a new yeah
ukraine had big uh
they're not stopping at ukraine the
russian
success what's that apparently you could
the ukraine had a big surprise
counter-strike offensive yeah the
largest they're [ __ ] them up yeah
but i've heard general talking he's like
yeah but when winter all russia is
waiting for his winner and winner comes
they're gonna [ __ ] him up so right now
ukraine's doing their thing once winter
come that's where russia excels
apparently
so i heard a five-star general say that
retired five-star general say that so i
regurgitate to my father and then he
shot back with fire
yeah the big worry is that what they're
really doing is they have these russian
mercenaries in their wagner group and
stuff and when they come in anybody
that's in those towns
they kill they're called the wagner
they're yes they sound very russian
i know but it's right there it's a
russian mercenary group they're like
they're like uh they're like a bad
blackwater you know these guys and they
come in and if you're in that town they
kill you and then what happens is they
keep moving oh yeah so that when they
retreat they don't have to worry about
people there so that's that's the ugly
ugly it's so much worse than people
think and every time they get kicked out
they [ __ ] come back in and they they
all the atrocities all the rape all the
[ __ ] torture all the executions it's
just it's so bad in ukraine right now
but they're they're giving it they're
giving it to them they're giving it to
you they're tough the other problem that
you allies are having the u.s is like
get your finger on my face you can't
you can't you can't um
give the the ukrainians
too much advanced weaponry because
there's a line in the sand where if you
you give them this crazy amount the
russians are going to retaliate with
something really drastic
so and i i figure most of our troops are
saying bring it on
i don't know man because then china gets
them back you realize how evil somebody
like the putin the russian regime is
they're willing to kill everybody yeah
for sure
that's war and the rules of engagement
with nuclear weapons too is different
than the united states says well that
would be they're more willing to a
disaster but we everybody knows that
they the russians are not stopping in
ukraine they would they would keep
rolling well then that's when we get
involved because they're nato yeah we
have to take over a nato country you got
our attention
and we're way tougher so people have
criticism of giving ukraine all this aid
and i don't it's a complicated thing but
i think the idea is to contain the
russians there and make them bleed out
in ukraine yeah so far yeah make them uh
you know whether the storm with them
make them as
yeah kind of not as dangerous when
you're fighting ukraine you've got to
kill those [ __ ] wagner those those
mercenary groups that are doing these
atrocities those are all the like the
chechenies and the
you know and they're they're a rough
group man they're
well i don't want to be disrespectful to
the chinese people because they suffered
terribly under the horrible soviets
under the russians under putin this the
chinese had their grozny was
reduced to [ __ ] rubble it's a war
crime so you know if i was it's very
hard for the chinese but you can just
get people you can get in the crazy
american news is funny right because
when the war first kicked off it was
everywhere and then they looked at
ratings like the americans are sick of
hearing about this and now it's just
like the war is not happening out of
sight out of mind but it's still
happening it's bad so basically after a
week
cnn and fox were like we'll just keep
you posted we'll let you know how to end
the only thing that the only thing that
comes out of that [ __ ] is like the only
good and it's not even a good is when
[ __ ] when i'm having a bad day i go i
could be ukrainian shut the [ __ ] up you
[ __ ] you privileged american yeah it
gives you perspective yeah that's it
what do we got man yeah man god we went
through some conspiracy [ __ ] dude i
gotta take my [ __ ]
silver tin head on wow
um god you kind of got me going though
gets the people going dude cuz i was all
set to be like get the [ __ ] out of here
most people are oh
there's a very popular rapper he was
he's out of philly he's based out of
philly he came to l.a he considers
himself an la guy but he's from
somewhere else but so he was eating at a
rosco's chicken and waffles with his
girlfriend his girlfriend posted a uh
instagram story where it showed the
location where they were at she tagged
him in the location where they're at now
if you have ops right year olds say no
ops so ops would be like people like
enemies and if they've been looking for
you and then your girl tags you and
gives your location you have all this
jewelry on and you're at roscoe's who
you know just be honest isn't in the
best area you know for that stuff it's
[ __ ] trouble man yeah so he was shot
and killed and they took his jewelry and
now his girlfriend
his girlfriend's getting a ton of crap
from even celebrities it's not her fault
she doesn't [ __ ] i don't know
it's bad enough she had to deal with
that also
the guy that i saw another guy from l.a
going you think there's not dudes
hanging out at roscoe's that would say
something but what what did did he have
beef with people or what i barely i
didn't even know about this guy until
the news camp to be honest
so including nicki minaj kodak black the
latter of whom wrote on south street
that whole mind is oh thanks guys that's
kodak black that's cool kodak that makes
the world a better place [ __ ] off like
first she's already dealing with a lot
now granted was it a stupid mistake yeah
yes the costumes life yes is it on you
no it's not on it's on the [ __ ] did
the [ __ ] person that that shot
somebody for their jewelry yeah was it a
revenge killing do we no they don't they
don't know it's it could just be i mean
it's still but it's been happening like
rappers i'm saying now like yeah
robberies are
like crazy so if you're you know you're
wearing flashy jewelry and watch and
stuff like that and you're posting
location and you're hanging out in those
areas well [ __ ] man can i make it any
easier on these guys so a lot of rappers
like dude la's the hub to get [ __ ]
jacked so carry carry
yeah yeah yeah it's horrible man well
it's just gang [ __ ] huh
did they catch this dude no they're
looking for him but they never attach
him and there are no snitch apparently
there are cameras inside the roscos i
don't know how good they are but they're
also making sure the cops are making
sure that all the pawn shops around the
area
just look out because the jewelry is so
very specific has his name everything so
terrible we have to go to the dark web
with it probably they just shot him like
oh wait wait wait wait there's struggle
yeah so you're telling me during this
mayhem that roscoe's chicken has video
photos oh dude now you're getting too
carried away bro now you're [ __ ]
taking a step i'm just
yeah sure so you tell me roscoe's
chicken has the capabilities but the
billion dollar company the ufc doesn't
have cameras
i'm just saying yeah me too it's very
strange i'm just saying but i'm a
[ __ ] dumb [ __ ] though bro it's so
[ __ ] up yeah that's terrible
oh i'll i'll just play this for you so
like popular in china
he's an influencer and uh he ate a wasp
live on his he's out of his [ __ ] mind
he's also awesome and he should have all
the views now this is the [ __ ] i'm
talking what a bad [ __ ] dude
that's what i'm have to do to sell
tickets about three years
start eating just wild [ __ ] we all are
we're if you can't keep up with this
[Music]
oh my god
so you can see it look at flapping about
right
zoom in on it that's a huge wasp
you'll see it closer
you can see it moving all right
[Music]
wait that's one of those
videos it's one of those japanese yellow
wasps they're in china i believe but we
checked this now that's china brian
the music is stupid but yeah
[Music]
holy sh dude that's so big brandon i
think there's more than one on there
it looks like there's two but
that's dangerous
oh he turned into howard the duck
now
now women in l.a pay a lot of money to
look like no no no
[Music]
so he had to go i think it's like water
rice but okay he had to go to the
hospital afterwards because he couldn't
he couldn't swallow he started swelling
up where those things but he said he
wants to do it again why
because to get stung again in that lip
yeah
well how many views does that have i
think he had like 700 000 or something
like that that's it you know something
like that eat a [ __ ] wasp chin you're
on that thing was funny you're on asian
tick tock yeah you're on chinese stick
though that thing that's the original
tick-tock yes
they banned it
uh they banned him from uh being in that
particular city can we see what kind of
wasp it is
i don't think it shows what i think it's
actually a wasp
i think that was a yellow wasp
biggest wasp i've ever seen in my
[ __ ] life that was the biggest one i
don't think i just said swallowing live
wasps that's the size of a small bird
that was like a sparrow-sized watch
americans we grew up on discovery
channel we know our wasp dude i'm a
subscriber to my boy coyote peterson i
know a difference between a wasp a bee
and you know what i'm saying a killer
horn that's a hornet bubba that's that's
a killer hornet nothing had abs bring up
killer hornet bring up murder hornet
right now
that thing had nothing had here watch
murder hornet i'm going to tell you what
it is giant asian [ __ ] hornet yeah
that's what he [ __ ] ate oh my god
that's what he ate bro oh my god yeah
now mark that guy's a bad do you know
why they call murder hornets why you
ever seen what they do to a group of
bees to get to the honey what you know i
see them rip heads off of honeyberries
five thousand they're crazy
dude just eating faces bro
[Laughter]
they just eat faces
there you go
it's one just one murderer that goes you
know what they have to try their honey
in here they try to cover them and they
slap their wings to make it so hot they
die but that's about all you can do
that's killing so that's him just
ripping the head off a prank that's a
mouse
what the [ __ ] dude oh my god he's taking
him for a ride dude
so they've got sick bjj as well
ah dude i don't know what's going on
here they're mating
those are those are two honey bees
bumping uglies wow well this isn't the
video we're looking for slaughter phase
that's what we want the slaughter face
so you can tell the difference look at
them going in there they kill they'll
kill 35 000 bees and rip their heads off
and get to the queen and then just eat
the larvae this video sucks
they'll eat the larva
oh god
that's got to be such i bet the bbc
won't be great but we could definitely
you know what they do so one of them
comes in
one of them comes in and scouts
and leaves a scent
right where the [ __ ] hive is and then
they all come back hey chain go back
that's him ripping the heads off these
little bastards you see look how much
bigger he is they can't do [ __ ] it's
like the bob sapp of wasp look at that
dude that's a monster it's a monster
they are really terrifying aren't they
yeah no thank god we don't have them out
here you think we have problems i don't
like that we get
in the ground i guess
i am very squeamish when it comes to
wasps
my boy coyote peterson got some see
stung by a giant hornet did you see that
40 million views yeah on his arm
try that on your [ __ ] face
i'll try it inside your mouth my daddy
was at one of my peewee football games
eating a taco bell burrito and a [ __ ]
horn it land on the burrito and he bit
into it it stung the roof of his mouth
come on my daddy was so upset
yeah that's gonna cause some problems
for you
yeah i get very squeamish about that all
right it's not good now here's the thing
about that video yep here you go so
we're talking about china so you know
i'm a fan of world star and you don't
want to play this game ruin your day so
there's a 10 year old and his grandma
was disciplined and this is in china and
the 10 year old went hey grandma she was
beating the [ __ ] on him he would say
grandma enough's enough puts her in a
headlock but he's 10 so he doesn't know
to like
all right you subdued her let go he
didn't like go and killed her
oh no yeah
i watched the whole thing yesterday this
video of it oh yeah some world star
watch on your own i don't like that
murder porn oh well no there's no porn
no but it's it's like you're watching it
to watch somebody else die yeah i don't
like that [ __ ] it doesn't make me it
doesn't make much oh no but it's in
there weird i'm like ah what the [ __ ]
dude what did he break her neck is that
what happened no he just held on for too
long so she didn't get oxygen to the
brain yeah and she's like hitting him
with a croc
uh like a soft thing she's hitting him
in him and then you see her go limp and
they hold it there for like another 10
minutes but the thing is is
his brother his friends filming it it's
like dude what are you doing yeah and i
don't know how it's going to work in
china when you do that you know i don't
know if that kid gets put away at a bad
time it's your your elder that's a big
deal in china
that's terrible so i'd bring the show
down all right well you know what china
does
everybody you want to know what the
china does why'd you just call me hold
on
what'd you just call me another minority
the uyghurs of the minority all right be
careful i say that the ccp the chinese
communist party has one of their
officials
living
living in the house
of a uyghur who's married to make sure
they don't have sex and have children
so you have to live with an official who
who whose job is to make sure that they
don't have intercourse
and have children
that's what that's what gee and the
chinese regime does sounds fun so what a
terrible way yeah so that's what goes on
that's what they're doing to the week it
is a straight
it's a terrible gig b it's a tough gig
because it's not like the chinese are
real loud when they're bumping and
grinding either you know they keep it
pretty quiet i i don't know the wiggers
are they're not he's like dude i can't
hear anything i sleep on the ground we
gotta sneak and i'm gonna i'm gonna
sleep between you can't have a baby i'll
hear you the government makes it out at
least and that's a fact and then what if
they do try to like it'll be like you
when chappelle and brian wouldn't bump
fist oh
anytime you give somebody that kind of
power over you you give government that
much power it's a matter of time before
one of someone like that or a group of
people like that comes in and decides
they're going to do that
so [ __ ] you yeah it's called the far
left so they can date and get married
and all stuff but they just can't bone
it so so they decided the uyghurs the
way you get rid of them without creating
genocide which would be very messy and
they've done they've killed a lot
they've re-educated them they take the
children away from the parents they put
them in these work camps all that stuff
they said we just can't have them breed
anymore
so they said we have the manpower
there's concentration camps out there
right now just yeah just take it i'm
sorry they're work camps they're
re-education camps and they still
and they go let's just get them to
[ __ ] uh we just will stop them from
breathing yeah so put somebody in the
house live with them that'd be a movie
i want to see that player movie someday
what what is that like for those two
that that that couple that can't sleep
with each other any more questions jane
mark
no we've educated you on wiggers
uyghur uyghurs wigger
weaver differently doesn't make it less
offensive brian that's right
um so ray j went on to say that
kris jenner actually had him and kim
kardashian
film another six sex tape to see which
one was better to make kim look better i
was before she
who actually got the tape they were like
they reshot the scenes i heard it a long
time ago and brilliant mom was involved
in it and then they [ __ ] with ray j
and he's like dude why do you keep
bringing my name up he goes i have the
receipts the show she shows the dms
between kim and ray j and he's like why
are you doing this blah blah blah you
know there's a second tape why are you
acting like this and she's like i'm
sorry i will have the lawyers call you
to figure this all out we're sorry this
caused you stress so he post all that
he's like i'm telling you i'm not
[ __ ] lying here yeah well i i that's
a 100 percent believe that and their
third sex david second they've been
trying to play you have to also sign off
on it to get out there oh yeah
and they didn't uh santa barbara sex her
mama made us go shoot it for safety
reggie said she watched the [ __ ]
and said hey we're gonna go with the
first one because the first one is
better it gives my daughter a better
look than the second one i made y'all do
that's chris jenner
yeah so nuts sell your soul oh my
goodness they're the sell your soul
richest family out here we're gonna do
hey how much of a savage is uh pete
davidson because obviously he had his
issues with kanye kind of was lighting
them up and then finally fired back at
him but he appeared at the emmys
and he wore the exact same outfit kanye
wore at the met gala oh my god yeah
really can i see that a carhartt jacket
and pants it's the exact same outfit
it's such a savage while he was with her
no no this is like two nights ago oh
[ __ ] that it that's the outfit yeah so
that jackets like car jacket can get
pretty much anywhere
so it's very strange he would wear this
like no one wears that to a ward show he
just did to troll
kanye west it's a savage move quietly
too damn
[ __ ] can we all just appreciate pete
davidson dressing like kanye for the
emmys peterson got a whole dickies fit
at the enemy's county about to have a
cow not pete davidson dressed up like
kanye at the emmys hilarious that's
incredible
and those were tweets from people
that's hilarious isn't that funny
ultimate power move yep this is a
a longer one but
it's i'll just edit part of it out but
this has been diesel so vin diesel
posted two different videos
because it was
um
paul walker's birthday
all right so he posted this and he's
just so freaking bizarre to me so here's
the video
it's it's a captioned miss you never did
[Music]
and how long is this him i'll just show
you this part beachfront
remember he's doing music
so all week
the angels have been asking how it's
gonna
believe that they can talk to you every
time they go to the ocean
so i thought i'd come
it's just more of this stuff and then it
ends by saying we you know we did it we
did fast 10. basically promoting
fast and furious and afterwards i i just
hate hollywood i
he's just completely i just in his own
what happens is you lose touch with
reality yeah yeah you lose touch he's
like you have to do this for your
brother don't have friends who go hey
bro if i did that you as my friend would
go i have to talk to you for a second
come here now i'm going to slap you a
couple of times because
well if you're doing it all the time
like he is but if you did that well if
you reenacted that and then posted your
dates i'm like that was hilarious well
that's different but then him who's
known for doing this weird [ __ ] and then
at the end to be like we miss you
brother fast 10 hits
[ __ ] december 7th are you [ __ ]
kidding me you didn't put the date but
he talked about fasting like dude yeah
i don't know that whole thing is that's
when you just don't have people around
you who are telling you you're a [ __ ]
dummy sometimes
your friends are supposed to keep you on
the straight and narrow because
everybody loses their way but if you're
treated like royal
for that long you're gonna [ __ ] lose
touch with reality that's a guy who's
lost touch with reality
it's you're not it's just it's just
embarrassing what's this
um let's have mark no now andrew tate
has signed with he's about he has a
platform now he's the voice he signed
with rumble
humble sign russell brand and andrew
tate rumble doing something you can't
you can't keep him down you can't keep
andrew
mentioning he was actually commenting on
um
math in this video so i thought you guys
might pick interested in just a
mathematics sort of analysis right here
in the newspaper the other day you can
recite pi to 200 decimals that's nice
but you look like a geek so who gives a
[ __ ] you ain't gonna get laid you're
going to club start reciting pie to a
hoe the worst game i've ever seen i saw
some [ __ ] kid in the newspaper
you can recite pie
i'm not that on board with that yeah
i mean i like that kid
i like that kid yeah
he missed on that one special comic book
is that a good game though is that a
game you were going to a club and
started reciting pie yeah but the kids
stopped the point that that kid is going
to be somebody's boss someday
literally i'm a fan of andrew tate with
something but some of it i mean i got
kids yeah well but i like that [ __ ] if
if he was older i'd be on board but when
it's a young kid it's just like
yeah you might not get the same shakes
you do reply and pie
you don't think it's that funny mark
there's no no you got a good sense of
humor you guys are taking it literally
like he's bullying a kid well the kid's
gonna know you guys can't see the irony
in that no no well no but maybe watch it
again
no i don't think it's like for me he
missed he is
do you think he's actually like
viciously
no no no no he missed that he did that
[ __ ]
he did that bit to be funny just missed
it sometimes you missed but it's okay
now with me there's three out of the
four people in the room and chin didn't
crack a smile
a lot of the stuff fighting i don't
crack a smile i don't either a lot of it
i agree with and a lot of it i'm like
yeah he missed there that would he
missed i don't have a problem with it
like you're gonna take some swings i
don't give a [ __ ] that's all right
i still like people until they don't
laugh at something i don't go oh i guess
i'm wrong no no no no no if you like it
[ __ ] yeah but i like
children and
i agree with most his stuff like most of
his stuff is funny like a lot of it's
funny we've defended him a lot yeah i
know i like andrew that was just a
clumsy move also
for me sarcasm irony yeah
yeah
for me
purposely but he and i are uh sensitive
because we have children
i mean about that also met children
before i think if it was an older kid
also kids for like if it was like an
older kid maybe i just that kid's not
yes yeah if he was if he was thirteen
it'd be funny i got an eleven no even
though that's about my kid he did that
about my kid i'd lose my [ __ ] mind
he's seventeen i got an eleven-year-old
kids are i've also had children before
yeah
yeah that's fine what else you got mark
what do you want mark mark got all
sensitive now now now mark's gone wait a
second mark's offended mark got offended
you guys just you guys just went no
that's not funny it's because of a kid
and you know like i have kids no we just
didn't know we didn't think he was funny
that's right yeah the two comics in the
room everybody the right you know what
you guys are obviously comics so
what you think is funny trump's what i
think it's funny
you can still oh you're taking it
personal like it's your skit though wait
wait wait wait
no it doesn't matter i get it just taste
different tastes yeah but again i i
wouldn't say i wouldn't leave you i
wouldn't leave a comment i wouldn't
leave a comment on there but like not
funny no no
that's fine it's fine
um all right but mark he can release
stuff on social media still or this
somebody else yeah what was that was
that because he can't didn't they ban
him from it
that was a youtube video that somebody
else made oh gotcha oh really yeah
because so he's still allowed to be on
youtube as long as somebody else no no
that's why he's on rumble that's why i
signed exclusively with rumble
now mark feels bad because people are
going to give him a hard time for me no
i'm not i don't do that no i imagine
kids no i imagine most people like if
you're andrew i get why i get why you
thought it was funny like i get i get
the idea of like he's he's it's kind of
an outrageous thing to do other people
saying something isn't funny no he's
clearly being to entertain there is
clearly being
he's clearly being over the top
sarcastic that's what he's doing and
again
because i get the joke as the kid he's
he's making fun of a kid he's not making
fun of the kid he's going dude you can't
chat a woman up and but the kid's never
going to be in a club so i get what
you're saying i get that yeah he i don't
think he's being funny he's making he's
making fun of memorize like you're
spending all the time but also the fact
that the kids i don't know what's going
on right now
we're analyzing it i get what mark's
saying is i'm trying to defend mark
because what it is is the kid's never
going to be in a club anyway chatting up
a girl so he's he's like hitting the kid
with you guys i think that's if anybody
takes issue with me laughing at this
joke he'll beat him up please no no i
won't beat him up
nobody's going to take issues
no i'll discuss it with them in public
or in private or don't
because it's just it's it's a non-issue
i just wish they would let them back on
[ __ ] social media yeah it's
outrageous which one mark what do you
like
um
chess grandmaster cheating scandal
alrighty
some chest masks we got
vibrating sex toy what
what's this mark
so there was a huge cheating channel
because this 19 year old beat an older
chess master hans neiman 19 at san
francisco caused a major upset when he
defeated norwegian grand master magnus
carlson 31 at the sink field cup in st
louis missouri now there's speculation
that he could have been receiving
hidden messages via things like
vibrating shoes or even
vibrating anal beads
and elon musk weighed in
uh and said on twitter talent hits a
target no one else can hit genius hits a
target no one else can see because it's
in your butt that's funny
so it was a major upset a stunning
result uh the chest world exploded into
such an uproar
um that he faced allegations of cheating
so it's basically so unprecedented
and that's so shocking and that's the
case um
jesus that might be the older guy
actually
oh no that is the kid yeah he's the 19
year old he likes that
furious
he doesn't look happy no
so he's saying it's outrageous and i
prefer not to speak
if if it never if i speak i'm in big
trouble and i don't want to be in big
trouble i prefer not to speak
interesting
i mean ain't no beats to win a [ __ ] it
at all whatever it takes man i like his
attitude if it's true
whatever it takes anal beads to win a
chess match who would have thought
um
oh that's the guy he beat guy's got a
big head that's a giant
that's a giant forehead no that brain
show you the big brain big brad big
brain with a lot of hair
that's a big old head
that's it the other guy gets the noggin
on him yeah he's kind of noggin
alrighty interesting
marcus
um i thought this was interesting
oh yeah another one
no
oh what should explain is tenzo gracie
yes video footage of martial arts legend
in an altercation on the platform new
york city subway station after coming
back from an academy gracie was having a
conversation with a fellow black belt
and staff member when he was confronted
for speaking
with his friends based off of
information we retrieved from an audio
recording on whatsapp gracie stated the
aggressor was a black dark-skinned man
who was yelling at him to speak english
here in the audio recording gracie
stated that the young man
accused him of speaking bad about him in
portuguese greece
the accusation was ridiculous and racist
a fight ensued according to gracie the
man begged to be let go
is saying i can't breathe yeah
that'll happen when hence gracie grabs
you that's going to happen and then
hence it goes you see you're a nice guy
why are you doing this why are you so
impolite yeah you're not gonna be able
to breathe when that guy
what is what is he doing doing there i
can't see
well he's got you now so he took him
down you're in deep water some ladies
like let's stop this
well clearly that guy was the ins he's
gonna wear you like a sweater buddy
here we go you got your world gonna go
from day to night
day to night my friend clean his face
nice
that's a replay right oh he's trying to
hit enzo and then the other black belt's
grabbing the lady who's cheeked up
trying to get into the middle of it
he got choked out
yeah that's that's so stupid put the
text right in front of it
yeah that's annoying
yeah you should put the text in front
but
you know brendan there are a lot of
cameras there and we did see a melee we
did see a tussle that's chaos we saw
some tusks that's weird it's like
somebody had their phones i'm just
saying somebody had their phone there
but ufc doesn't
i think that was coms out that looked
like comes out
kevin holland yeah because that was a
wrestling thing and
um so i don't know
shark jumped into the boat give us that
one yeah
now this is only scary if the
kind of shark is it thank you
i would assume
oh also that looks like an infant
juvenile great white which would be kind
of scary
oh so they're fishing
[Music]
yeah that's what i said
that was so fast
uh make
no i called it first
right right right
piggybacked on that look at that
released back in the ocean what a
beautiful animal oh makos are sweet
looking yeah
after that
video of the guy losing his finger that
quick i'm getting nowhere near sharks
this is oh that thing i go fishing all
the time too it'll take everything i'm
not going anywhere near its mouth i mean
you can get in there just don't put your
[ __ ] hand in front of it no even like
this if i saw a shark jump in the boat
i'm running
what i enjoy about this video mark is
that that's not some [ __ ] black tip
i hate that those are stupid
strong black tips are the prius of the
ocean they're harmless they're stupid
you know true
i swam with them when i was in bora bora
no no and then you lied to me tony's
great whites remember that i don't
remember that sir what's the last one
ukrainian ufos do we actually have
footage
do we have any [ __ ] footage these are
probably 100 drones ukrainian
astronomers claim ufos everywhere over
kiev
that's an old video
we see them everywhere we observe
significant number of objects
in nature
flights of single group squadrons of
ships are detected moving at speeds from
3 to 15 degrees per second drought
yeah it could be some russian drones
in america
nato's using drones
uh the ukrainians are being given drones
it would make sense it's drones over a
war right so we can see what exactly
they are 100 using drones right now
weaponized drones now real quick uh
brian do we really do are we just going
to chalk up all this [ __ ] to drones even
the ones in america like when our
fighter pilots like the navy sees them
it's not that i don't believe that
aliens exist and it's not that i don't
believe that you don't have that
universe there's definitely life but not
i don't think they i don't think when
you see those pictures that that's ufo
you're going to believe my dumb ass
conspiracy
i don't believe that that's an action
it'd be funny if i just died now no
i mean there has to be some sort of
footage of aliens i don't think that on
this earth we have footage it's always
so [ __ ] blurry it's like the comes
out kevin holland thing where's the
video all i see is a bunch of no
movement but i don't see the actual
spartan kick i don't see the actual
fight sure that's all i'm trying i'm
asking questions can i get one clear as
day
look at it you're asking the right
question not a [ __ ] thing with a
light that's moving up and down you want
an actual green alien with antlers well
i think cameras work pretty well
nowadays especially in military and
great times technology so i'm just
asking can i get some video but if you
listen to bob lazar right i'm just
asking for some evidence not your
hearsay yeah i hear you're saying i'll
tell you what's not a conspiracy i will
be in ontario california this thursday
friday saturday ontario come get some
ontario improv is this thursday one show
thursday two shows friday two show
saturday and then a week off gotta go to
a funeral for my grandma next week and
the week after that september 29th
through october 1st dana white's
hometown boston massachusetts on that
laugh boston it's almost sold out dana
white's uh family can get free tickets
and then san jose october 13th through
the 15th salt lake city wise guys one of
the best clubs october 20th 22nd all
right club and then just announced
calgary canada i'm coming up i've been
there about five years i'm at a club
called the rooftop and there's one show
on the 27th and they're going to add a
show on the 28th because that [ __ ] is
selling calgary canada come get some but
this week ontario europe and the mike
stud
um thick boy collab will be available
only in person in ontario in person and
in boston in person so whatever we have
left can only get in person that's a
save a horse rider thick boy hat and t's
are available in person only at ontario
california ontario improv this thursday
friday saturday tickets at fakeboy.com
san jose california this weekend
thursday tomorrow friday saturday uh
come get some at the san jose improv
briancallen.com for tickets spokane
washington the following weekend
september 22 23 24. i'm in spokane i
can't wait uh and then i got tacoma
comedy club i stay up in washington
september 29 30 october 1. and then
bridgeport connecticut stress factory
october 13 14 15. daddy's going to get
back to the east coast yes i am i got
that's
that is the law those other three are
pretty easy that i don't mind going up
or down it's when i gotta go across yeah
with that [ __ ] time difference yeah
it'll eat you too it kills me
is that it dude that's it thanks for
entertaining my dumbass thanks for
giving thanks for getting me to ask some
questions yeah no problem dude this the
final kid we're out